good afternoon
my name is bill summers I'm
of the Dwight H Terry lectureship
committee and it's really my great
pleasure to welcome you and introduce
today's Terry lecture professor Janet
Brown of Harvard University the Terry
lectures invite preeminent scholars in
religion the sciences and philosophy to
address issues concerning the ways in
which science and philosophy inform
religion and religions application to
human welfare this lectureship was
established in 1905 by a gift from
Dwight Harrington Terry of Bridgeport
Connecticut and is among GL's most
distinguished lectureships
it is yielded important and enduring
books published by Yale University Press
mr. Terry's deed of gift states that
quote a series of lectures be given on
ethics the history of civilization and
religion biblical research all Sciences
and branches of knowledge which have an
important bearing on the subject and the
great laws of nature especially
evolution this year's Terry lecture
professor Janet Brown the Ehrmann
professor of history of science at
Harvard admirably suits
mr. Terry's intentions as she is one of
the world's leading scholars on the
lifetimes and impact of Charles Darwin a
compelling historical figure who exerts
a continuing influence on our time
Janet's interest ranged widely over a
history of life sciences in the natural
history
after a degree in zoology from Trinity
College Dublin she turned to history of
science and received her PhD from
Imperial College London her first book
the secular arc presciently published by
Yale University Press traces the history
of naturalist interested in the question
of how species are distributed around
the world
she is also written on the history of
museums specimen collecting and botanic
gardens since then she has specialized
in reassessing Charles Darwin's work
first as associate editor of the early
volumes of the correspondence of Charles
Darwin and more recently as author of a
major to volume biographical study that
integrates Darwin's science and his life
and times
while it was framed as a biographical
study this work explores the ways in
which scientific knowledge was created
distributed and accepted moving from the
private to the public widely read by a
general audience brown's darwin
biographies have been described by
various reviewers as Magisterial
monumental dazzling definitive brilliant
and a masterpiece her work has won
several notable libery and scholarly
prizes including the Pfizer prize from
the history of science society she has
served as editor of the British journal
for history of science and was president
of the British British society for
history of science professor Browne was
for many years at University College
London before moving to Harvard in 2006
professor Browns Terry lectures are
entitled becoming Darwin history memory
and biography and today she will speak
on Darwin as an economist of nature it's
with immense pleasure that I present you
my colleague and good friend professor
Janet round
thank you Bill thank you for those very
generous words and hello thank you all
for coming
as you can imagine I'm immensely honored
to be invited to give these lectures and
to follow in the footsteps of so many
distinguished other speakers and
thinkers I wish particularly to thank
the Terry lectureship committee and the
chair professor Martin and my colleagues
bill Sommers gene Black for their very
generous hospitality and I'm awfully
glad also to welcome my colleagues and
friends from here and other places to
hear me today it's a delight and thank
you very much so I wanted to start by
talking about James Conant who was a
previous speaker in these Terry
lectureships quite some time ago 1946 he
was at that time the president of
Harvard University that small town to
the north of here and he had the
privilege of delivering tarry lectures
at Yale he spoke about the need to
provide a better understanding of
science to those people who have no
intention of becoming scientists and he
went on at Harvard to promote the
teaching of popular science by means of
case studies which we do continue to do
more or less to the present day is many
other achievements as a transformative
post-war president at Harvard included
the promotion of co-ed classes and
adopting an early version of the tenure
system for professors he also abolished
athletic scholarships presumably not
quite realizing the importance of the
game for those of us living on the
eastern seaboard and drawing on the
lectures he gave here in Yale he
established the history of science
department at Harvard where I work so I
take special pleasure in acknowledging
these interconnections and
I'm very glad to be speaking here at our
sister university yet currents vision of
the history of science did not embrace
any of the approaches that we now call
systemic or political religious or
cultural nor did he express most much
interest in gender issues or the media
or any parts of the world beyond Europe
or North America so despite his
admirable commitment to explaining
science by using history currents
approach was lightyears away from what
happens today in the department that he
created and in this series of lectures I
aim to use history of science as it
stands today to explore what sort of man
the Victorian naturalist Charles Darwin
might have been and to push that story
into the 20th and 21st centuries to ask
how writers and artists have constructed
and reconstructed his personality
successively in the years beyond and
this will perhaps be a familiar story to
many of you for which I apologize his
place in history as the celebrated
author of on the Origin of Species
of course his firm he must be one of the
most studied figures in the history of
science and Bill very generously
mentioned some of the words that have
been used to describe my biography but
he didn't mention beak so there's an
awful lot of work on Darwin which I'm
going to be put drawing on today I'm
very grateful for this work by other
people and that work now reaches into
popular culture very extensively and
other disciplines such as art literature
poetry and economics yet I do think it's
a story worth retelling I've called this
series of talks becoming Darwin because
I hope to address the historical
processes that have generated the figure
of Darwin that we customarily encounter
in the media today the modern Darwin as
might be expected represents modern
issues
he's often represented as an intrepid
explorer in contemporary science
documentaries he is plagued by religious
doubt in the movies he is photoshopped
into satirical images on the web and
he's often presented as a champion of
biodiversity in museums in some parts of
North America you will know that he is a
person who school children are
recommended not to believe sometimes he
appears as a character in a play
sometimes as an artwork occasionally as
a fridge magnet and frequently as a
bumper sticker he's a part of modern
commodity culture and I just want to
show you that there's a mountain named
after Darwin there's many many variants
of food purveyors this one is in Dublin
not actually when I was a student in
Dublin but it is in Dublin now without
the apostrophe I'm sure you'll notice
there's a number of other food kinds of
food stuff there's quite a strong line
of beers produced with Darwin's name in
the place where he was born
grossly in the United Kingdom there are
movies which some of you may have seen
this one is the creation movie published
issued in the year that was darwin's
bicentenary 2009 that is very good in
parts
and what I would love is you're thinking
of buying me a Christmas present
there's the lego voyage of the Beagle
with all Darwin's shipmates as look at
characters to stick in the ship and here
is Darwin himself who you'll recognise
and this evening I want to dwell on an
aspect of Darwin's character that opens
up what I think is a different way of
thinking about the interrelations
between his science and his family life
this aspect of his character could be
called the accountants view of nature I
wish to explore this both literally as
seen in Darwin's own family account
books his financial books and his
investments and figuratively as
expressed in metaphors in his theory of
evolution by natural selection and my
hope is that we'll come to see that
Darwin believed that sound financial
management in his home not only
contributed to the contemporary ethos of
the respectable upper classes of Great
Britain and that he in this activity
drew very obviously on the prevailing
world of Malthusian political economy
but that accountancy was also his way of
being a virtuous and moral man and
virtue is a theme that I shall be
raising again in following talks
together we can reflect on the way that
Darwin emerged as the most famous
natural philosopher of his day
simultaneously praised and reviled for
having thrown God out of nature and we
can look together at how he has become
an emblem for science first of all as an
icon for secularization for the secular
world for rationalism and more recently
as a figure who enables people to talk
to one another about the fundamental
tenants of belief and how they may fit
in the modern world which I take to be
part of the
for the Terry lectures so thank you and
first a little background so accountants
are underestimated people although their
methods as Ted Porter and other scholars
reminders reflect key features of the
scientific method in that they rely on
precision the control of data and
standardization and my interest in
Darwin's accountancy was sparked by a
comment made by him in response to a
printed questionnaire which I have here
for you sent to him in 1873 by his
cousin Francis Galton and in that
questionnaire Darwin was asked to list
the mental qualities but he thought
contributed to his scientific success it
had been sent out by Francis Galton to
all the fellows then of the Royal
Society of London and the returns came
to supply the basis of Galton's first
vegetarian study called English men of
science their nature and nurture
published in 1874 and as our colleague
Dan kevlars has shown whom dance here
tonight this was the period that golden
was developing the idea of eugenics
which he went on to define in 1883 so he
was interested in Darwin because of his
fame as a scientific thinker and also
because he was his cousin they were
related through their grandfather dr.
Erasmus Darwin the evolutionist poet and
physician and golden felt that he and
Darwin most likely shared several
scientific characteristics through
inheritance the questionnaire was seven
pages long I've only given you the top
bit here covering family background
physique health mental traits education
politics and religious belief it's
actually quite illuminating
and at the end of this questionnaire
golden asked each man of science if he
thought he possessed any special talent
and we might nowadays imagine expect
Darwin to have said that he was very
good at observing or he was very patient
in collecting evidence or that he had a
long-term love for Natural History those
are the kinds of things we might expect
instead he answered that he felt he had
no special talents none accepted the
business as evinced by keeping accounts
replies to correspondence and investing
money very well very methodical in all
my habits he wrote and it's that Darwin
that I want to explore today with you
the methodical man who rated his skill
in investing money and keeping accounts
higher than any other quality that he
might possess so Darwin kept a series of
camp books from 1839 and sorry about the
poor quality of this reproduction begun
ten days after his marriage to the
morning and kept to the morning of his
death in April 1882 he used the system
of double entry bookkeeping that he had
learned from his father Robert Waring
Darwin and one set of books was
concerned with investments there's the
cash book that you have here and there
was a series of Ledger's which I shall
show in a moment daily transactions were
jotted down in the cash book like this
and he was very careful to date it and
to check off on the left-hand side when
he had transferred that amount into the
ledgers he even recorded the the cash
that he took out for himself as in this
cheque but you can see we don't get
checks sent back to us anymore from our
banks
our statements come out every month but
that was the practice usually but
nevertheless it's quite rare to find a
check signed by Darwin drawing on his
own account something must have gone
wrong with the system that it's still in
existence today so that's an unusual
item although it looks terribly mundane
periodically the details were entered
into Ledger's and this is an annual
ledger with credits on one side and
debits on the other again I'm afraid
it's too small for you to see but I
couldn't get the whole of the book in
without making the writing almost
indecipherable this was the sums were
totaled on an annual basis with the
expenditure divided into categories
classed as Darwin called it and year by
year he could track expenditure on
defined categories of goods and services
and here is one such of those Ledger's
the classed accounts and this one shows
science on the left his annual
expenditure on science and his annual
expenditure on Gardens on the right and
you can see they're nearly Gardens as
two-thirds more than science here's a I
hope slightly enlarged version of that
you can see that on the left his science
accounts for that year really don't run
too much he mentioned Sowerby who was
giving him who was providing
illustrations for his Barnacle book this
is Qasim for translations his insect
Britannica and here's another case on
translations not very much spent on that
and on the gardens you can perhaps see
that there's this Brooks and Brooks
again Brooks down here again it's the
name of his gardener that's his salary
and then occasionally we have potatoes
here's more potatoes that seep seed
potatoes and here are cattles seeds and
plants so that was made he was obviously
planting for the summer season here's a
mowing machine that too is quite unusual
for Victorian England that was towed by
a donkey it wasn't a mechanical machine
so that under this double entry system
the credits and debits should exactly
match they should add up to zero at the
end of each accounting period and it was
a system designed to reveal errors if
you were an actual accountant it
revealed errors or fraud and we can see
Darwin on other pages identifying his
small annual errors and correcting his
balance sheet
Darwin's investment books naturally
excite a great deal of comment they show
that from the middle years of the 1850s
he usually made an income of some six to
seven thousand pounds English pounds and
from that money he invested some two or
three thousand pounds so they lived on
about three thousand pounds per year and
he invested the balance of his income
his portfolio included what you might
expect government stocks railway shares
canal and Dockyard schemes plus some
farmland in East Anglia that had been
bought for him by his father as a rental
concern and several loans in the form of
mortgages raised on property carried
over from his father's death Darwin
inherited these loans at a very healthy
interest rate of more than three percent
it's not easy to work out exactly how
much he was worth every year because
income tax returns weren't invented you
could count it up from these Ledger's
but I haven't done so but we know that
he began married life in January 1839
with a marriage bond given to him by
father of 10,000 pounds 573 pounds in
the bank and 36 pounds in his pocket
that's his total financial income by
1881 the year before his death when his
banking son William added everything up
they were making his will a little more
up to date that son had increased to to
two hundred and eighty two thousand
pounds excluding the profits from his
books so it was a very healthy sum
indeed and I'd like to correct just in
passing a common myth that most of
Darwin's money came from his marriage to
his cousin Emma Wedgwood shown here Emma
Wedgwood was the granddaughter of Josiah
Wedgwood the entrepreneurial China
magnate who permanently altered consumer
culture during the Industrial Revolution
in Britain she's seen here in her
marriage portrait that was intended to
be paired with that of her husband
they're very rarely seen together quite
like this as a marriage pair done by the
same artist George Richardson but you
can see they're not done at the same
time there's nearly a year that was in
between these two so they don't match in
any way the coloring is very different
but Emma Wedgwood certainly brought
capital into the marriage her marriage
bond from her father who was Darwin's
maternal uncle amounted to five hundred
five thousand pounds half of what
Darwin's trust fund was and Charles
Darwin her husband and two other family
two other family members managed this
money on Emma's behalf because women
were not legally able to own property
the interest on Emma's money was
reinvested for her by Darwin it was not
spent nor was it available to her so to
speak and on her death the accumulated
capital
amounted to some 24,000 pounds which was
split between the children as a direct
inheritance so it was her security
really for when in case Darwin died
while she was still alive so the family
in essence lived on the interest on
capital that came into the marriage in
1840 it was managed entirely by Darwin
as the head of a Victorian household and
the English historian Harold Perkins
well described this category of the
upper middle classes in Britain in the
first half of the 19th century whose
assets often originated in manufacture
but were usually converted into paper
wealth as we see exactly here in the
Wedgwood family and the ownership of
land property and estates over the
course of several generations and the
Wedgwood family was one of Perkins's
best examples of that process now where
am I going with this these account books
reveal something significantly geeky
about Darwin and that's what I want to
dwell on for Darwin
I think this constant attention to
financial matters the regular entering
of figures the adding up of credits and
debits became a way to create rigour and
certainty in ceaseless flow of
information and activity even when he
was on the Beagle voyage he was very
careful to keep his records straight or
as straight as he could he separated
lists of fossils from his lists of
plants or his zoological specimens or
his rocks and minerals and by middle
life nah not that time I wish to dwell
on my middle life when he was working
hard on evolutionary theories long after
the Beagle voyage was completed he seems
to have become rather compulsive about
lists and records so you'll know perhaps
but he kept a daily diary a journal that
he calls in which he counted the precise
days weeks and hours that he was able to
work each month this shows the page from
his diary in which the origin of
species' was completed you'll see here
that he says that he's finished proofs
and it took him 13 months and 10 days
just there 13 months and 10 days he kept
a diary of his poor health which perhaps
wasn't as compulsive or preoccupation as
we might think because this was usually
what a physician would ask a patient to
do before or after a consultation in the
19th century he kept a record of the
books he had read and was about to read
so here we have two pages two ends of
the same notebook turned upside down and
these two notebooks were very early in
his evolutionary thinking he didn't
always cross them off from the books to
be read but here you can see the books
read that he's deleted them he finished
the pages in that notebook and by 1856
he had begun another one but this time
he optimistically called it books most
certainly to be read famously he opened
a series of notebooks which we've now
called the evolutionary notebooks
lettered from A to E and then another
miniseries called M and M in which he
explored evolutionary ideas he kept
another notebook for his experimental
ideas and some of the results of his
experiments he kept a list of the
pigeons that he was breeding he kept a
list of the barnacles that he was trying
to dissect he kept lists for everything
he ran a voluntary Savings Club for the
laborers the farm laborers in the
village where he lived in Kent and later
expanded this into a penny
savings scheme that would help the
participants pay for winter fuel for
which he kept the accounts and submitted
to the relevant government body every
year so this compulsion to record and
order data reached into all quarters of
his life his long-suffering household
Butler who was called Joseph's past
parlor maid Manilla brown paper folders
labeled by subject matter for his master
to put slips of useful information as a
homemade version of a filing cabinet you
may not be able to read this terribly
well because he habitually this is
Darwin's handwriting habitually used an
orange crayon or a brown pencil to write
this says embryology folder twelfth in
which he would put all his embryology
notes he made notes on the early
development of his children and these
same children later helped him in
compiling a shelf catalogue of his books
even his recreations were subject to the
power of the written record over many
decades he kept another small notebook
in which he recorded the results of each
game of backgammon that he played with
his wife and in a letter to Jane Grey
the wife of Lee Harvey botanist ASA gray
he once wrote now the tally with my wife
in backgammon stands thus she poor
creature has won only 2490 games whilst
I hath won hurrah 2795 games
so it's not only recording it's also
competitive and most well-known in this
tendency for an accounting mode of
thought is the document Darwin wrote
when considering the case for getting
married I am sure many of you have come
across this but it's called at the top
its pros and cons left and right marry
or not marry this is the question and
there's a number of things that I'd like
to draw to your attention here draw your
attention to here on the not marry side
on the right I won't read the whole of
it but you'll see it begins with no
children no second life if he not
married he'd have freedom to go wherever
he liked choice of society and little of
it conversation of clever men in clubs
not forced to visit relatives and to
bend in every trifle Bend in every
trifle have the expense and anxiety of
children perhaps quarreling loss of time
cannot read in the evenings fatness and
idleness anxiety and responsibilities
less money for books and on the merry
side over here on the left
he begins making the case for the things
that he's already detailed on the right
so he starts with children that's an
advantage of getting married if it
please God he'd have a constant
companion down here a constant companion
and friend in old age who'll feel
interested in one object to be beloved
and played with and then you've seen he
puts up here in the margins better than
a dog anyhow
charms of music and female chitchat
these things good for one's health but
terrible loss of time my god it is
intolerable to think of spending ones
whole life like a new to be working
working working and nothing after all no
no won't do which is in the middle here
and then down at the bottom he says just
just picture to yourself a nice soft
wife on a sofa with good fire and books
and music perhaps compare this with the
dingy reality of great Morris Street
which was where he was living in London
at the time Mary Mary Mary
QED so there's something about all this
that is interesting and it suggests a
man who worked best if the data were
ordered and categorized and I think it's
not a trivial matter I think we can see
here the same language of time
productivity and labor that we see
elsewhere in the developing industrial
economy of Great Britain perhaps the
same language that his grandfather
Joseph Josiah Wedgwood used when
reorganizing his factories more than 50
years previously through the division of
labor
Darwin was adopting a style of living
and working that emphasized the
collection and comparison of data and
was also more broadly participating in
the shift that then underway towards
standardization and tabulation of
information that underpinned the
emerging Victorian way of life
increasingly dominated by railway
timetables for example actuarial tables
population censuses the collection of
medical statistics as well as the
division of labour seen in the factories
so economy of time to Darwin and to many
of his contemporaries was thought to be
a source of wealth
knowledge so here in these annual
accounting books lies a natural economy
that directly relates to Darwin's sense
of himself as the head of his household
judging from that response to Galton's
questionnaire that I showed you at the
beginning he apparently came to judge
himself as a husband and a father almost
entirely by his ability to manage money
and to provide for his growing family by
9 1859 when the Origin of Species was
published he and Emma had seven
surviving children of the ten that were
born to them here is Darwin and his
oldest son William on the left and Emma
Darwin Len is not the youngest son he's
the youngest by three but Darwin and
Leonard here taken by the process of
daguerreotype which is why they're
rather poor in reproduction you know
daguerreotype so you have to sort of
move your head to catch the image
because they're on engraved silver in
this case and they don't photograph very
well for this kind of purpose you'll
find with the next image as well that
the family clearly had a bulk order for
these kind of clad materials so here is
Emma on the left with her last child
Charles Waring Darwin who died at the
age of 18 months from scarlet fever and
here is Henrietta who becomes Henrietta
Litchfield in later life and writes a
very interesting biography of her mother
and Anna Darwin who died at the age of
10 who was slightly older she's the
oldest daughter so there were seven
living children seven children who lived
to adulthood out of out of the ten so
Darwin had a lot of children to account
for - to deal with to finance he had
governesses he had school bills he sent
the boys away to Publix
which in Britain is private school and
he had a large house in the country
yeah very beautiful large house in the
country and he had a staff to manage so
accounting in this regard genuinely
represents the input of a man of
property that was looking after all the
people and the land under his teachers
so I think these annual inspections of
his resources provided some form of
reassurance that he was fulfilling his
role as the head of his household and
the eagerness with which he compiled the
figures also suggests that proper
accounting was the way by which he
judged his own moral status as well for
his own virtue we might say accountancy
was also a form of accountability the
English historian William Ashworth
describes the way that credit worthiness
in science as in business was usually
based indeed had to be based on a
person's accuracy probity and
self-discipline remember too that by
then Darwin had no direct belief in God
in his life by the middle years of his
life he had given up most of the
conventional institutions of
Christianity he didn't believe in
baptism he didn't believe in the words
of the Creed he didn't wish to see his
sons sign the thirty-nine articles he
didn't go to church doesn't mean to say
that he rejected all the divine in any
thought of the divine he wrote that he
thought by the time he was writing the
Origin of Species that he deserved to be
called a theist so that he wasn't
completely rejecting the sense of the
divine but he had no direct
image oh that's kind of support of an
active God in his life so that good
management of the family finances came
to signal his sense of commitment to the
moral structure of the Victorian world
that he was doing his duty that he was a
good man that he was virtuous that he
looked after people and that he did that
through an orderly life rather than
going to church let's see
so keeping accounts was for him as for
many other Victorians a tool for probity
and self-discipline as well as a way of
becoming a virtuous member of society
now this is the very point that Thomas
Robert Malthus made in his essay on the
principle of population Malthus had
argued that sooner or later populations
human human populations if they continue
to grow in size will be checked by
famine or disease or by other kinds of
illnesses and that this situation was
divinely imposed on humankind expressly
to teach virtuous behavior the
profligate laboring classes as
characterized by Malthus were accused of
not only increasing endlessly in number
but also of spending any money that they
had they did not save they did not think
ahead
they lived only for the day he wrote by
contrast has also described by Malthus
the respectable middling kinds of
classes tended to save their money and
to think ahead these commonplace
cultural assumptions rang true to Darwin
and to many other members of his circle
and like most of his contemporaries he
ascribed moral virtue to those qualities
so such Malthusian
political economies of course appeared
in on the Origin of Species they
reappeared again in Darwin's descent of
man published 12 years later in 1871
where he explicitly declared that the
accumulated wealth of the prosperous
classes and it seems to me that he was
thinking of Great Britain here the
accumulated wealth of the prosperous
classes was the key factor in the
emergence of a civilized society
these are Darwin's words a civilized
society he said was one that emphasized
the rule of natural economic law the
balance between those who labor to make
wealth and those who spend it in a more
or less harmonious design carrying moral
significance and cultural advantage for
nations and this is a quote from the
descent of man he said the presence of a
body of well instructed men who have not
to labour for their daily bread is
important to a degree which cannot be
overestimated as all high intellectual
work is carried on by them and on such
work material progress of all kinds
mainly depends not to mention other and
higher advantages so I'm wanting to say
here that the natural theological
framework of Malthus is writings was
brought by Darwin into his theories of
evolution by natural selection
we know this it's not contested but I'm
proposing here that it was also Malthus
meant something to Darwin in terms of
the moral value of looking after his
money and looking after his family so we
could almost say that Malthus his
writings were secularized the natural
theology was taken out by Darwin but
nevertheless was important in the way
Darwin's thought about his
home life and his scientific work and
turning now to the role of money as
metaphor I want to propose also that
Darwin's account books or his accounting
frame of mind might equally have been
seen by him as an aid to conceptualizing
animal and plant evolution I want to
stress that there's no evidence at all
to suggest that his account books were
causal in generating his theory of
evolution by natural selection the
chronology doesn't fit and we know far
too much about the way Darwin came to
think about evolutionary theory and then
formulated the idea of natural selection
we know that it wasn't his account books
that did that for him all I'm trying to
say is that there was metaphors that are
sort of useful to him in his middle life
when he was those long years spent
justifying and verifying the astonishing
power of natural selection theory
so under this point of view where money
serves as a metaphor for natural
selection an animal or plant might be
regarded metaphorically as possessing
debits and credits in the natural
economy where each favourable adaptation
might add to an organism's individual
capital each profitable adaptation
leading to a consolidation of market
share this is exactly what he was doing
and seeing in his investment books and
the matter was not completely fanciful
the word species in evolutionary biology
after all derives from the old financial
term species for money for coinage the
language of Accountancy is intended to
make objective generalized statements
out of many individualized transactions
and perhaps these activities of
real money carried out over a long
period of time with such regularity
could have provided Darwin with a way to
visualize the probability of a small
number of favorable variations
maintaining their place in a larger
population sufficiently long enough to
invest their biological capital until a
stage was reached where profits could be
reaped and dividends distributed such
symbolic capital could be composed of
adaptive traits and like monetary
capital could perhaps be converted into
all kinds of resources necessary for
activity and profitability so Darwin's
view of nature emphasized as we all know
the acquisition and retention of
advantages here in a nutshell is the
central theme of natural selection
nature could perhaps however also be
seen as a monetary economy just as
easily as it was regarded as a political
economy as I'm coming to a conclusion
now more than 40 years ago the English
historian Robert Young argued that
Darwin's system of biological change was
deeply interconnected with 19th century
economic thought this isn't news to us
however it was a provocative claim back
in the 1960s calling on a special blend
of Marxism and Cambridge University
intellectual history that required
converts to adopt what Jung called the
common context in which the leading
ideas of science literature theology
philosophy and economic theory
circulated freely amongst the elite such
claims would hardly be contested today
everything we now know about
structure and language of evolution by
natural selection indicates that Darwin
drew on malthus's si of the principle of
population that text provided Darwin
with the central ideas of competition
struggle and survival and over the space
of a few days in September 1837 helped
him construct his mechanism of natural
selection so we know Malthus was
important for Darwin that text was also
important for Alfred Russel Wallace the
other man in the evolutionary story and
provided Wallace with his central ideas
of competition struggle and survival and
this mutual reliance on Malthus was
surely one of the most astonishing
features of the simultaneous yet
independent formulation of the concept
of evolution by natural selection by
both Darwin and Wallace in the middle
years of the century and the mutual
reliance on Malthus was surely also an
important component a major element in
the shock that Darwin felt on receiving
Wallace's letter in 1858 that indicated
that Wallace had a theory of evolution
by natural selection
so since Robert Young's time we've
become accustomed to see Darwin as a
member of the elite manufacturing
classes familiar with commercial
concerns well-versed in the
entrepreneurial ethos of an expanding
Imperial marketplace for British Goods
subscribing to liberal reformist agendas
and adopting all the values of the new
industrial society including what
perkins has called the middle classes
transition into paper wealth so it's
probably no surprise to see him
endorsing the accumulation of financial
assets and endowing the process with a
civilizing moral status as he did in the
descent of man
these sentiments evidently had a real
meaning for him as a member of the
moneyed classes to him I'm making a bold
claim here to him the acquisition and
preservation of capital was clearly a
worthy and moral endeavor his private
life and his scientific life merged
together here in this idea of virtue as
expressed by financial probity and the
keeping of accounts that he mentioned in
his response to golden so many
historians have attended to
record-keeping as a significant factor
in the process of manufacturing power
and knowledge the establishment of a
numerical paper record is seen as a key
stage in systematizing and analyzing
otherwise unintelligible entities all
nation-states have needed the authority
of numbers to control to understand if
we want to be Foucault daeun about it if
we want to follow the works of the
French philosopher Michel Foucault we
could say that the numbers were also
used to confine a population in various
ways and keeping accounts has long been
recognized as a pivotal element in the
emergence of capitalism and the rise of
bureaucracies alongside of modernity and
further than this there are real
theological echoes ancient geological
occurs in bookkeeping practices that
speak of entering moral credits and
debits into the Ledger's of life of
divine judgment of being called to
account on the day the final day and
although we don't have time to go into
the history of accountancy you'll know
that it's Babylonian in origin
very early route and was naturalized by
the Catholic and Protestant traditions
keeping accounts was part of a more
general rhetoric of orderliness that
came to a peak in the industrialized
England of the 19th century the
vocabulary of efficiency as colleagues
of mine
Ted Porter Rainey - Susan Faye cannon
and others describe it the vocabulary of
efficiency was then elevated by the
Victorians into a distinctive voice of
the times a voice that was
simultaneously moral scientific and
numerical so I'm suggesting today the
first of my three talks that there's a
great deal of virtue in this sense of a
moral economy and it's virtue that I
shall be moving onwards with in the next
two talks Darwin's economy of nature can
be seen as a moral economy and as an
economy of the household and I've tried
to argue today that this trio of
economies were aspects of a single
deeply rooted element in his character
that of making lists Darwin's commitment
to keeping accounts surely helped him
make his daily life into enterprise that
he believed was virtuous that
crystallized everything he understood
about life in the intellectual
prosperous classes of mid Victorian
Britain so directly and indirectly
I think this practice lay at the heart
of his great project to understand
evolution by natural selection and his
amazing book his fundamentally
distinctive book On the Origin of
Species by means of natural selection
thank you very much
well you've touched on the truth those
notes on marriage I think were intended
to be private he had written some
earlier ones a month or two beforehand
that are often also used in scholarship
these marriage notes are very frequently
now read aloud at marriage services you
may have come across that it's very
charming at least the bit about the dog
is often the bit that's allowed so I
think they were meant to be private they
were kept and we know that he showed
them to his wife to be because there are
some jokes about the notes and we know
that he either she or Darwin himself
showed those notes on marriage to his
daughter who got married and as far as I
understand it they remained private
until the Darwin papers came to the
Cambridge University Library in the
eighty nineteen fifties because for many
many years many decades manuscripts were
not really part of what people needed to
know about Darwin the private life was
not the scientific life if the
scientific life was fit to being the
important achievement so I as I
understand it the answer to your quick
question quick answer to your question
is that no they weren't meant to be seen
but then shyly we imagine romantic
moment he said to his wife to be you
know I I did work this all out
oh thank you very much there there's
there seems to be an obvious connection
between this predilection to lists
making and ordering and and so forth and
taxonomy and that sort of thing
I remember from from my early work lives
how much I enjoyed doing performance
analyses in business and I often like to
think that there's a connection between
that and my enjoyment of science and so
I I wonder if you are able to see
something like a connection or a
conjecture about the fact that he's very
involved in investment and he's coming
up with with causal theories later yeah
thank you so you're they're tightly
interwoven so we know that Darwin really
enjoyed his investment he liked to
follow these investments they I don't
suppose The Times newspaper in those
days had a page of share prices like
they used to decades but he would turn
to the business pages of the newspaper
before the other pages so he enjoyed his
investments he thought he was good at it
he enjoyed a little speculation
occasionally but he was never taking
risks the interrelation of running a
they didn't have things like
spreadsheets so he couldn't have run a
projection but he asked his
knowledgeable acquaintances how they
thought such-and-such a railroad company
would turn out he was very interested in
the Philadelphia docks and he wrote to
somebody in the States to ask him were
they really as successful as was being
reported in Britain he would write to
his brother to say what do you think
about X or Y for Emma's trust fund so
there's a lot of engagement I'm not sure
really answering your question but I
think we could confidently look at
Darwin
a person in Victorian England engaging
in investment with the thank you for a
fascinating talk
I believe we now understand that Darwin
abhorred slavery and and spoke out
against it
so I'm kind of intrigued by the idea of
it was probably quite common in amongst
his group his social group in Victorian
England to feel quite happy with
themselves and their moral status and
all the rest but all around them we know
of course there was great suffering in
Victorian England and throughout the
Empire and you know of course I'm
thinking also of the famine in Ireland
the Darwin ever comment either in
writing or as far to other in letters
about the plight of the poor other than
from some Malthusian thing which sounds
terribly hard-hearted for my hero but
that he you know that basically if
people behave like that that's what they
got and and you know I'm sure he didn't
think it was divine providence because
he had dispensed with that theory but is
there anything in his writings or his
letters to that effect thank you thank
you really tough an interesting question
to follow through so we do know that
Darwin had tremendous distaste for
slavery but we also know that that
didn't stop him investing in cotton
manufacturers or the sugar trade or some
of the other things that came with the
plantation
colony of Britain at the time he perhaps
was able to separate these two but his
moral sense of every individual was the
same we're all brothers and sisters
under the skin was very pronounced
so his social views and his kind of
investment views were not fully
integrated with his humane views his
sense of humanity and if you read the
desmond and more book about slavery
darlings vision anti-slavery beliefs and
those of his family you'll see that
they're very astute about that
disconnect whether that's something that
many people that darwin social class had
I'm unable to say but for Darwin himself
he was fully respectable prosperous he
believed in accumulating wealth in order
to advance the arts and civilization to
look after his own family and he
understood that much of that was based
on interest rates drawing on farmers who
perhaps aren't able to supply that money
drawing on laborers he didn't invest in
was followed some of the accounts of the
emigration we know he followed the ebb
and flow of the civil war with great
great passion that he was very much for
the north the abolishing slavery but
there's a disconnect and you put your
finger on it it's just hard hard to
connect those two bits together
then how to shout
wasn't it usual for the head of a large
household with many staff members and
children and in fact multiple households
to keep accounts of this sort in other
words were these records of Darwin's
unusual in some way or for the time
thank you
they are unusual in that they've been
kept that they're available and that's
because Darwin was famous so there must
be many many accounts that were kept
that just got lost yes there's a very
substantial number of household accounts
that are made available through the
British Library and other places I would
imagine that's similar in the United
States and other places it's just that
they're usually in Britain if you'll
forgive me they're usually connected
with the aristocracy the biggest States
always had factors people who did the
accounts so that the accounts of the
biggest states are really quite well
known and very copious from the 16th
century to the 19th century something
like Darwin's household accounts are not
so usual to find and here we've got a
terrific thorough complete record from
1839 to 1882 it's astonishing every
toothbrush we have I know where he
bought it toothbrushes every merino wool
what the British called vests underwear
we know where he bought that we know the
price it is unusual I think that we have
that in so much detail something you
didn't mention but is very relevant is
that it's mostly men who make these
accounts so Emma Darwin
had her own accounts for the household
that we know her husband required her to
do because she was a bit she didn't
really feel the need to do that but he
wanted to know how much the meet cost
that candles cost them how many pigs
were bought and he totaled up Emma's
accounts at the end of the year and put
them into his account and if I had been
writing a more gendered account
description of this I would have made
the point that in fact Darwin was sort
of appropriating the financial details
that Emma had been in charge of so she
had a cash book she had income that he
gave her that she spent but then he
wanted to know how she'd spent it so
thank you that's a helpful question
seem to remember from some years ago an
absolutely delightful and personable
display at the Museum of Natural History
in New York and if I remember correctly
part of the end of that was a letter
written by his wife expressing her pure
happiness in his character partly
because he loved animals
and I wondered whether we had any
anything much that she had written that
might cast light on her attitude toward
his accounting especially as apparently
hers was co-opted into it
yes I can only recall one at the moment
which I'll mention in just half a second
his son Francis who wrote the
introductory chapters to Darwin's life
and letters after his death the son
Francis says that he recalls how anxious
his father would get if he wasn't able
to record expenditure in his cash book
and that he would digit and reach for
his cash book and wasn't settled until
he had written in the sixpence for the
toothbrush and we know that Emma Darwin
probably for many many things she had
and I'm going to be sentimental here she
had a very affectionate kind of
non-committal view of her husband and
she like wrote to one of the daughters
to say your father's been doing his
annual accounts again we're all in
penury and we were all in penury until
he discovered a page where he had
miscalculated and so everything's fine
and so yes of course it was a very
prevalent part of the household we don't
live with them but we could perhaps
imagine that this was a very regular
part of his daily life
Janet you mentioned golfing early on he
was well-known for passion for penalty
whatever you can count do you see any
connection between his propensity for
counting and darlin I don't mean genetic
but I mean by way of example by way of
family training the two cousins could
well have had that same sense of needing
to know things in numbers rather than
very abstract things so one of Darwin's
big characteristics and I've gone on
about it a lot this afternoon was that
he really liked to know things in
numerical form but without being a
mathematician or a statistician or a
calculator in the sense that his cousin
Francis Galton was who really I mean
that'd be a talk he was really
compulsive about making his whole
experience with the world be turning
that into numbers Dan was written about
Dalton's very wonderfully they the sense
that a human physique could be turned
into statistical tables the proportion
between the hand and the elbow and the
shoulder
so the anthropometric devices that have
gotten invented in order to do this he
invent so many of the statistical
techniques that we use today the core
with regression and various kinds of
correlations he's the next generation
after Francis Gorton were deeply engaged
in what they called biometrics the
measurement of evolution evolutionary
trends so the two of them are very much
the same but we could perhaps include a
whole bunch of other scientists who were
equally engaged with numbers that
weren't golden
so I'm sure they're learning the
technique of double entry bookkeeping
you have to learn that it doesn't come
naturally and that's a family's a
practice that they learnt I mean I don't
want to sound genetic about this but yes
there was a family tendency to record
things yes they were not only they were
obsessive
okay so let's examine that is obsession
a family characteristic well I know this
is being recorded but I would say yes
perhaps we'll change that commitment
hello I've been under the impression
that Darwin kept a very short workday
were they just thinking of his doing
science and writing science and not
thinking of his managing the household
deed did he really have a lot longer day
than we give him credit for or some
quarters give him credit for what an
interesting question thank you so he was
in action all the day and when he says
said in his reminiscences that he only
worked for a couple of hours a day he
meant hard thinking writing work the
rest of the day was maximized to be
effective doing other things like he
would be reading what he'd be doing
correspondence or he'd be doing his
accounts or he'd be taking a walk or
thinking he would be having a rest so
the day was a long day no longer than a
normal day but a long day and like most
of us he learned how to maximize and be
most effective that he did his heavy
duty working early in the morning then
you would have a late breakfast then he
would do something else then and so on
and so on so the work day but the
writing work the books I think Professor
Brown has had a long day today let her
finish now and I'll invite you all to
join us for a reception at the other end
of the hall in this building right after
we accept this thank you and watch this
space for more